is the Democratic base leaving Barack
Obama behind plus the Democratic fresh
faces are in trouble in President Trump
promises to end Obamacare again I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show a
[Music]
lot coming up for you on today's show a
lot of Joe Biden some Bernie Sanders
basically it's two old people slapping
at each other with the balls from the
bottom of their Walker so it's getting
real weird out there we'll get to all
that in just a second first let's talk
about how you send your mail this year
no one really has time to go to the post
office which reminds me last time I went
to the post office I got a parking
ticket I have yet to pay so I'll do that
after the show but that's why I don't
really want to go to the post office and
that's why you should use stamps calm
it's one most popular times having tools
for small businesses stamps calm
eliminates trips to the post office and
saves you money with discounts you can't
get even at the post office
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service direct
to your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices and online
sellers shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps calm can handle it all with
ease simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
or drop it in a mailbox it is indeed
that simple with stamps calm you can get
five cents off every first-class stamp
at up to 40% off Priority Mail not to
mention it's a fraction of the cost of
those expensive postage meters stamps
calm is a no-brainer it saves you time
and it saves you money it's no wonder
that over seven hundred thousand small
businesses already use stamps calm right
now my listeners get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and digital scale without
any long-term commitment just go to
stamps comm click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
Shapiro that is stamps comm enter
Shapiro for that special deal four-week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale there's a reason I use stamps calm
at home and we use it here at the Daily
wire stamps calm enter Shapiro for these
special deal alright so Joe Biden
continues to be top of the news as
Democratic Party struggles to deal with
the accusations that he's very
touchy-feely now I'll acknowledge that
it's weird that for eight years the
media had nothing to say about this
everybody on the right mocked Joe Biden
incessantly for years for being the guy
who would go to a diner and suddenly one
of the constituents the female
constituents would end up on his lap the
guy who had stroke the faces of other
people I mean Joe Biden has been weird
about
stuff for a very long time I mean this
has been his theme for a very long time
and there is nothing new here now
there's a second woman claiming that
Biden quote touched her inappropriately
at a Greenwich fundraiser in 2009 but
again the headline here doesn't really
match the story this is from the
Connecticut Courant and basically their
argument is that this Connecticut woman
said that Biden grabbed her by the back
of the neck and then rubbed noses with
her like that's a weird thing to do but
is it a sexual thing to do is it like a
sexual harassment thing to do it's weird
for sure it's an invasion of personal
space for sure but Joe Biden has no
limits Joe Biden has no limits when it
comes to his speech he just says
anything he has no limits when it comes
to his personal behavior he just touches
people weirdly but that doesn't that's
not the same thing as Al Franken
grabbing a butter a boob so the the kind
of overblown controversy about Joe Biden
being Joe Biden it's just funny to watch
as the standards change on him and he is
eminently confused about all of it which
frankly I think it's appropriate
considering that the standards did
randomly change on him now the Democrats
are a lot more hesitant to throw Joe
Biden off the cliff than they would be
if this person were a Republican
obviously Nancy Pelosi the Speaker of
the House she said does this disqualify
Joe Biden from the presidency no that's
that silly I think it's disqualifying I
think it qualifies with what your
intention is I do think this about
communication in general I know if Jim
about in a long time my grandchildren
loved you by I mean he's a he's an
affectionate person to children to
senior citizens to to everyone that's
just the way he is okay so yeah Nancy
Pelosi basically saying he's been like
this forever why are you all of a sudden
proclaiming that he's doing something
deeply terrible or inappropriate and
that seems to be sort of a bipartisan
take Laura Ingraham last night on her
show should listen Biden is touching me
before and it didn't bother me because
he's not trying to sexually harass me I
have to share with you just really
quickly my own touch-and-go moment with
Joe Biden okay this is many it's
probably 10 years ago I wrote about it
one of my books at a party in Washington
was that George Will's house and Biden
saw me at the entranceway to the party
so Biden comes up to me I went up to him
I
remember what and he put his hand both
hands on my shoulders and he said God's
honest truth Ingram you're my favorite
of the right-wing crazies there's
something like that to that effect and
he looked up and he said how you doing
and he was funny it didn't bother me one
bit but that's kind of who he is but now
that's being used against him by the
people who want to knock him out on the
left and I gotta say it's it's it's rich
but it's probably undeserved and and
that is pretty right by Laura Ingraham
right there centrist from Laura Ingraham
Whoopi Goldberg on the view said the
same thing she said you know it's kind
of weird that the lady who first came
out and said something about this woman
in Lucy Flores happens to be a supporter
of paedo O'Rourke just you know this
happened five years ago what are you
sitting around waiting five years to
talk about it now I agree with all this
I'm just gonna point out the insane
irony of the same Whoopi Goldberg who
said the Brett Kavanaugh should be
kicked off the Supreme Court for a
thirty-year-old allegation without any
evidence mad same Whoopi Goldberg is
saying why this lady wait even five
years to talk about this supposed Horror
Show that she experienced with Joe Biden
Stephanie Carter who was the wife of
defense secretary ash Carter published a
blog Sunday defending Joe Biden over a
viral photo don't keep jig
misrepresented nervous in that picture
Joe Biden knows that yeah he was behind
you whispering so so you have to stop
characterizing stuff mischaracterizing
it that's all so for her it was a
comfortable experience for the other
woman it was not but don't sit and wait
and say I'm uncomfortable on national
television right because it makes a
suspect of you are weird weird how that
standard has now changed when it comes
to Joe Biden by the way same standard
has changed when it comes to Alyssa
Milano I thought the most ironic tweet
of yesterday was Alyssa Milano tweeted
out something about Joe Biden how much
she likes Joe Biden she tweeted out a
picture of herself with Joe Biden
suggesting that she and Joe Biden got
along and that she'd never had these
experiences with Joe Biden her actual
tweet is a picture of her next to Joe
Biden at some sort of event and she says
quote I am proud to call Joe Biden a
friend he has been a leader and a
champion on fighting violence against
women for many years and I have been
fortunate to accompany him to events
with survivors where he has listened to
their stories empathize with them and
comforted them
that's who drove iDEN is a warm generous
individual who believes it's on all of
us to pay attention
to women's stories and experiences Biden
started its on us because he believes to
meaningfully change our culture everyone
including those often left out of the
conversation like college athletes and
frat brothers need to be part of the
movement Joe Biden's response that he
never meant to make anyone uncomfortable
and then he'll listen and learn from
anyone who says otherwise is exactly the
leadership we need to build a culture
where women are heard and are equal
I respect Lucy Flores his decision to
share her story and agree with Biden
that we must all pay attention to it but
just as we must believe women that
decide to come forward we cannot assume
all women's experiences are the same
I believe that Joe Biden's intent has
never been to make anyone uncomfortable
and that his kind empathetic leadership
is what our country needs especially now
so ironic because I remember Alyssa
Milano getting in a Handmaid's Tale
outfit and traveling over to the Supreme
Court to proclaim that Brett Cavanaugh
could not sit on the Supreme Court
because of an old allegation with no
supporting and verifiable evidence I'm
old enough to remember that because that
was like what six months ago within six
months she has shifted her tune and now
her experiences with joe biden disproved
the experiences of other women with joe
biden again i don't believe the joe
biden he's running around sexually
harassing women i don't i think he's
real touchy and i mean he's a weird dude
but i don't think that he's running
around sexually harassing women i'm just
pointing out that folks on the left have
radically changed their standards
because you'll remember that during the
Cavanagh hearings Kavanagh brought
forward a letter from a bunch of former
female colleagues who suggested that he
was actually great with them and the
left head well that's not proof of
anything that's not proof that he's
innocent I mean he could have been nice
to these women and not nice to I mean
the same thing is true for Alyssa Milano
but you don't see the left saying the
same sort of stuff so there is a certain
irony to to the left
new attitude with regard to Joe Biden
but there's something deeper going on
here and that is the left seeking an
excuse to make a break with Joe Biden
the hard left seeking an excuse to make
a break with Joe Biden which really is
the left seeking to make an excuse for a
hard break with Barack Obama see here's
the thing about Joe Biden he was not
just a senator if he'd just been a
senator he wouldn't have any shot in
this election whatsoever I mean he tried
in 1988 he tried again in 2008 he failed
both times really miserable well now
he's running as the Vice President to
Barack Obama so he's running with the
with the sort of emblem of Obama on his
shoulder he's running as Barack Obama's
third term and the hard left is
not supremely happy with it it's kind of
fascinating they think they've moved
beyond Barack Obama Barack Obama for a
lot of members of the intersectional
left was actually a Waystation he was
not the the final form of the destructor
he was not the the ideal Barack Obama
was just a moderate guy it's amazing how
Barack Obama becomes a moderate in the
minds of the Democratic Party but now
Barack Obama was a moderate guy with
moderate policies and we've moved beyond
Barack Obama we don't need him anymore
he was a stepping stone in the same way
that for every past president they
become moderate in hindsight the same
thing is now happening to Barack Obama
and the Democratic Party doesn't want
moderate so there are two separate
columns in the New York Times today all
about why this is the wrong time for Joe
Biden and basically they both come from
the same place that Joe Biden is past
his prime that we don't need anymore
this Obama shtick anymore Michelle
Goldberg who's legitimately an awful
columnist I mean the New York Times
editorial page is filled with awful
columnist I'm hard pressed to say that
Michelle Goldberg is not even worse than
Nicholas Kristof which is one hell of a
recommendation for her she has a piece
on April Fool's is from yesterday called
the wrong time for Joe Biden he's not a
sexual predator but he is out of touch
okay so let's get this straight he's not
a sexual predator he's not a sexual
harasser but he doesn't understand women
properly and therefore he cannot be
President here's what Michelle Goldberg
writes on Friday
Lucy Flores a former Democratic
candidate for lieutenant governor of
Nevada accused Joe Biden of touching her
inappropriately as they waited to take
the stage at a 2014 election rally he
put his hands on her shoulders she said
the nuzzled her hair and kissed the back
of her head she didn't accuse Biden
who's reportedly close to announcing his
presidential candidacy of sexual
harassment or assault just of making her
uncomfortable I'm not suggesting Biden
broke any laws but the transgressions
that society deems minor or don't even
see as transgressions often feel
considerable to the person on the
receiving end she wrote in response
Biden released a statement saying that
while he's often been physically
affectionate as a politician not once
never did I believe I acted
inappropriately then on Monday a meal a
post a former aide to Democratic
congressman Jim Himes told The Hartford
Courant that Biden pulled her toward him
to rub noses during a 2009 fundraiser
there's absolutely a line of decency
Lapo said adding crossing that line is
now grandfatherly it's not cultural it's
not F it's not affection it's sexism
or misogyny Biden's campaign hadn't yet
begun and was already in crisis
Flores lapis and Biden says Michelle
Goldberg are probably all telling the
truth
there are countless photos of Biden
behaving in the ways floors and
lampposts describe squeezing women
rubbing their shoulders leaning into
clothes all this was open not furtive
presumably because it never occurred to
Biden he was doing anything untoward I
don't necessarily blame him in the past
few years women have been calling out
daily indignities that previous
generations grew up quietly tolerating
lingering hugs from boss embarrassing
intimate questions crude office jokes
individually these are smo acts and most
men probably don't understand how cumin
cumulatively draining they can be women
after all have only recently begun to
articulate it
I received plenty of unwanted shoulder
massages when I was younger and for a
long time I assumed there was something
wrong with me when they made me flinch
it was affirming to finally realize that
other women also hated routine invasions
of their personal space but if it wasn't
always obvious to me that the men were
at fault in these awkward and awkward
encounters it might not have been
obvious to them either so I don't think
the Biden's avuncular polling is a
me-too story but biden was more
oblivious than predatory his history
still puts him out of step with the
mores of an increasingly progressive
Democratic Party and here is where we
get to the crux of the matter I'll
explain in just one second first let's
talk about how you get ready for work in
the morning
I love the Dollar Shave Club has
everything I need to look feel and smell
my best but I love even more is the fact
that I never have to go to a store
that's because first DSE delivers
everything I need directly to my door
and second they keep me fully stocked on
what I use so I don't run out here's how
it works
Dollar Shave Club has everything you
need to get ready no matter what you're
getting ready for they've got you
covered head-to-toe hair skin face you
name it they've got it and they have a
new program where they'll automatically
keep you stocked up on the products you
use you determine what you want when you
want it shows up right at your door from
once a month to once every six months
that's what I do for Amber lavender body
cleanser it is calming and soothing and
smells delightful plus but they're
handsome discount the more you buy the
more you save right now they've got a
bunch of starter sets you can try for
just five bucks like their oral care kit
after that the restock box ships regular
size products at regular price so what
exactly are you waiting for get your
starter set for just 5 bucks right now
at dollarshaveclub.com slash Bend that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash men go check
them out dollarshaveclub.com slash men
get that starter set for just 5 dollars
right now and then the restock box ships
regular size products at regular price
fantastic deal dollarshaveclub.com slash
man you're gonna love their product it's
great stuff so Michelle
berg spelling out the real reason the
democrats want by now at least some
democrats went biden out the reason is
because biden is not in step with the
times and they're not in step with the
times biden is not in step with the
times because he is an emissary of the
obama administration which has suddenly
become to right-wing for a lot of
progressive democrats here is what
Michelle Goldberg writes she says on
Sunday the New York Times reported that
some Democrats are bracing for an
extended reckoning about mr. Biden and
gender if he enters the race the
inevitability of such a reckoning should
make Biden reconsider getting in Biden's
issues with gender after all go far
beyond chronic hands eNOS his waffling
on reproductive choice troubles many
feminists as The Times reported last
week Biden's back and forth over
abortion would become a hallmark of his
political career in other words he has
said in the past that he is personally
opposed to abortion and this is no
longer okay with the base of the
Democratic Party he was the chairman of
the hearings on Clarence Thomas's
Supreme Court nomination where Anita
Hill who accused Thomas of sexual
harassment was demeaned and dismissed
well that's because Anita Hill was
probably not telling the full truth as
witness testimony made clear no Biden
has express sorrow for how he'll was
treated he's never directly apologized
to her beyond gender on issue after
issue if Biden runs for president he
will have to run away from his own
record he and by extension we will have
to relive the debate over the Iraq war
which he voted to authorize he'll have
to explain his vote to repeal the
glass-steagall Act which by lifting
regulations on banking helped create the
conditions for the 2008 financial
meltdown that by the way is a bunch of
nonsense it was not the glass-steagall
Act removal that led to the financial
meltdown it was the government
sponsoring subprime mortgages and
backing them and letting hedge funds
know that if they continued to invest in
subprime mortgages the government would
essentially cover for them in 2016
Hillary Clinton was slammed for her
previous support of the 1994 Violent
Crime Control and Law Enforcement Act
which contributed to mass incarceration
Biden helped write the law so here is
where the Democrats are starting to
disavow Barack Obama and Joe Biden the
old Democratic Party must die to make
room for the new Ross dude hat makes the
same point over at the New York Times
today now dude had obviously is a a
Republican but nonetheless he is not
wrong to point this out so dude hat has
this piece in the Newark Times called
the real Joe Biden decision he says at
some point soon Joe Biden is going to
have to make two decisions the first is
whether
to run for the Democratic nomination the
second is whether he wants to win it and
at what cost right now even after some
slippage Biden has the highest polling
numbers of any candidate in the race he
also has a record that is completely out
of step with his party's activists an
ideologist a highly familiar personal
style and a base of support that's
roughly as old as he is this combination
makes it easy to imagine Biden running a
campaign that ends up feeling like an
apology tour in which he talks endlessly
about much how much he has learned and
groaned since the days when he was a
tough on crime Democrat who opposed
school busing and sometimes voted for
late term abortion limits some of the
ideas apparently bandied about by his
aides a one-term pledge Stacey Abrams
his running mate fit with this strategy
in which the goal would be to
established Biden as a temporary bridge
to a woke her future a candidate ready
to put his moderate past behind him and
serve the new liberal consensus that
kind of Biden campaign would probably
lose and Zita would probably lose as
badly as Jeb Bush did why because in a
big primary field with a lot of flavor
of this available it's very hard to hold
your base if you aren't giving that base
a clear reason to vote for you this of
course is exactly right from Ross to hat
and he points out that on social issues
he is out of step and on racial issues
he is not considered woke enough so what
exactly would Biden have to do he'd have
to appeal to all of these groups openly
and directly which would require taking
ownership of his record not defending
everything not avoiding all apologies
but arguing explicitly that some tough
on crime policies were necessary and
some moderation on abortion should be
acceptable that the Ocasio courtesan
turn on economic policy should be
questioned and resisted and yes
defending his personal familiarity but
his Biden gonna do any of that stuff
first of all I think it would be good if
he did but he's not gonna do any of that
stuff
and so Biden has a problem I've been
saying for legitimately weeks on this
program the best day for Joe Biden is
the first day for Joe Biden every day
after that is a worse day for Joe Biden
and if he thinks that Barack Obama's
gonna provide cover to him he's got
another thing coming
Obama is not going to endorse him in a
primary and that means that Biden is out
there on his own Biden has logorrhea he
runs on at the mouth all the time he has
diarrhea of the face the man says things
on a routine basis I know we all pretend
that Joe Biden is some sort of elder
statesman Joe Biden has a long record of
saying dumb stuff all the way back in
2008 you'll recall that he famously
called Barack Obama a different kind of
african-american presidential candidate
clean and articulate that's the
person who Joe Biden is when he is on
the campaign trail we really think he's
not gonna make those kind of gaffes
again and there's also another point
which is even if Barack Obama were to
enjoys to endorse Joe Biden would that
be enough to put Joe Biden over the top
because there is a gap between the base
of the Democratic Party and the
mainstream of the Democratic Party the
progressive woke left of the Democratic
Party which is disproportionately white
by the way not minority a lot of those
folks are not particularly fond of
Barack Obama they see Barack Obama in
the same way that for example Ilhan Omar
has described Barack Obama as a guy who
is droning terrorists in foreign
countries and was too conciliatory
toward Republicans yes that's a wild
rewriting of history but that doesn't
matter to a lot of the progressives in
the base so an Eric Holder the former
Barack Obama Attorney General goes out
in public and he says things like Trump
will be seen as one of the worst
presidents but Barack Obama will be seen
as one of the best I don't know how many
members of the Democratic Party base
actually agree with this this is him
with ari Melbourne on MSNBC yesterday
last to Donald Trump we just got to
survive these next 22 months or so I
think he is in danger of being the worst
president in the history of the United
States Barack Obama history's gonna be
extremely kind to Barack Obama I don't
say this because I was his friend or I
was his attorney general I studied
American history over time he is the
estimation of him by historians will
rises it's already begun he is gonna be
a top five okay so yeah that may be true
for the moment for older Democrats but
already Barack Obama is fading into the
gauzy kind of sepia gaze of history and
he is no longer considered the leading
edge of the woke brigade he's been left
behind
Eric Holder is is trying desperately to
grab that mantle he's desperately trying
to keep the focus on Barack Obama as
leader of change but the fact is that
that's not something that I think a lot
of Democrats are resonating to which is
why they are moving over toward
Alexandra Ocasio Cortes it's why they
are moving over toward Bernie Sanders
it's why everybody who's discounting
Bernie Sanders in these primaries I
think is getting this stuff completely
wrong I think that if you are if you are
really already dismissing Bernie Sanders
you're getting this stuff absolutely
incorrect there's a poll out today that
shows the Bern
Sanders has a double-digit lead among
young voters Bernie Sanders explicitly
rejects the legacy of Barack Obama and
Bernie Sanders is a full-on statist
socialist he likes to proclaim that he's
in favor of Norway I mean dude was in
favor of the USSR when the USSR was
still around dude was campaigning for
Venezuela like 10 years ago but he has a
double-digit lead among young voters in
the 2020 Democratic presidential primary
according to a poll released on Monday
31 percent of likely voters between 18
and 29 favored him Joe Biden trailing at
20%
that's a terrible number for Joe Biden
among young voters bethe O'Rourke is at
10% that means that Bernie Sanders is
tripling tripling bata O'Rourke and he's
a full 33% ahead of Joe Biden or 50% if
you're measuring from the Joe Biden's
perspective no other candidate has more
than five percent of the young support
that means that Sanders is dominating
among Millennials and he is dominating
among socialists and that may be enough
to win him the nomination
that is a fundamental rejection of
Obama's sort of quasi fusionist ideology
here's the truth about Barack Obama deep
down in his heart he believes a lot of
the same things that Bernie Sanders does
but Barack Obama was also a consummate
politician so he would say things about
how much he likes capitalism he would
say things about how much he was in
favor of an American military that was
still muscular in the world he said a
lot of those things I don't think he
believed a lot of those things but now
the Democrats are saying we want to say
those things and believe those things
the legacy of Barack Obama is a failed
Obama care program that is not Medicare
for all but legacy of Barack Obama is a
man who launched a war in Libya and got
us involved in Syria the legacy of
Barack Obama is a person who increased
taxes somewhat but not dramatically and
did not increase social services in any
massive dramatic fashion
that is how many young Democrats see
Barack Obama so this attempt by Joe
Biden to glom on to the Obama legacy I'm
not sure that that benefits him in any
serious way in the second I'll give you
Joe Biden's I'll give you Bernie Sanders
his fundraising numbers they're stunning
they're stunning and you'll see Bernie
Sanders attempting to cross over I have
said for weeks on this program for
months probably that I think the Bernie
Sanders is the frontrunner for the
nomination I think that is still true I
think the octogenarian socialist is
actually the front-runner here I'll
explain
in just one second first let's talk
about those credit-card bills that
you've been racking up for decades
credit cards have been telling us you
can buy it now and pay for it later with
interest despite your best intentions
that interest can get out of control
really quickly with Lending Club you can
consolidate your debt or pay off credit
cards with one fixed monthly payment
since 2007 Lending Club has helped
millions of people regain control of
their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to a
bank no high interest credit cards just
go to Lending Club com tell them about
yourself how much you want to borrow
pick the terms that are right for you if
you are approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion dollars in loans issued go to
Lending Club comm slash Ben check that
rate in minutes borrow up to 40 grand
that is Lending Club comm /ban this is
the responsible thing to do I mean if
you've got those debts running away from
you you need to consolidate and Lending
Club can help you do it go check them
out at Lending Club comm / Ben that is
Lending Club at comm / ban all loans
made by web bank member FDIC Equal
Housing lender Lending Club is helping
millions of people regain control of
their finances and you can be one of
them check them out at Lending Club com
/ man check that rate minutes borrow up
to 40 grand Lending Club com / Ben so
Bernie Sanders is raising money up the
wazoo right now the first quarter
estimates have come in and Bernie
Sanders has raised I kid you not 18
million dollars in the first quarter I
mean that is dominant dominant how
dominant is that number well Pete but a
judge was being given all sorts of
credit for for raising some 18 millions
or 18 million dollars Pete but a judge
would be given all sort of credit for
raising seven million dollars in the
first quarter Bernie Sanders is nearly
tripling him Kamala Harris came in at 12
million dollars Bernie Sanders
apparently has 28 million dollars in
cash on hand and he also just raised 18
million dollars I mean he's running away
with the money race and the longer Bert
and the longer Biden waits to get in the
more money is going to go toward Bernie
Sanders who has the highest name
recognition in the race it's pretty it's
pretty astonishing and Bernie knows
where the heart of the Democratic Party
is the heart of the Democratic Party is
with that radical progressive base so
Bernie Sanders is now doing the racial
pandering that you know I was earlier in
the race I suggested that Bernie Sanders
might be better
the country then Kamala Harris simply
because he wasn't doing as much of the
racial pandering he for example had said
he was not in favor II favor of slavery
reparations
well now Bernie Sanders is repeating all
the woke talking points in the hopes of
drawing a significant percentage of
black votes and by the way that could
happen
I talked yesterday about a 538 report
suggesting that he does not win a
disproportionate non share of the black
vote he doesn't underperform among black
folks Hillary Clinton just over
performed among black folks it is not
certain at this point that Kamala Harris
over performs among black voters
according to the new Quinnipiac poll the
person who is scoring best with black
voters is Biden followed by Bernie
Sanders so here's Bernie Sanders at an
event yesterday talking about how
Republicans are suppressing the black
vote which of course is not true I say
to those Republican governors and
attorneys general all over this country
for working overtime to try to suppress
the vote for people of color for young
people for poor people in general what I
say to them from the bottom of my heart
is that they don't have the guts to
participate in a free and fair election
they should get the hell out of politics
and get a new job okay that is just not
true okay it's just not true that the
black votes have been suppressed in the
United States blacks have been over
representing their percentage of the
population at the ballot box since 2008
this is simply not a true statement
but Bernie knows that he asked to say
the sort of stuff and he has no problem
saying this sort of stuff
because what does he care he's running
for the nomination he's doing the same
thing with regard to Planned Parenthood
I'm like Joe Biden who at one point had
said he was sort of split on abortion
Bernie doesn't have that record to worry
about he says it is anti-woman to defund
Planned Parenthood the leadings the
nation's leading abortion mill
responsible for some 300,000 abortions
per year go see the new movie unplanned
if you want to see what Planned
Parenthood actually does on a daily
basis but here is Bernie saying at his
anti woman to the fund Planned
Parenthood I mean dudes running to win
is a strong supporter of Planned
Parenthood
I want to applaud the grassroots
activism of Planned Parenthood and
standing up and not only fighting
against these horrific anti-woman
of legislation that we are seeing all
over this country but standing up and
saying that women will not accept and
men will not accept the defunding of
Planned Parenthood so that millions of
women will no longer be able to get the
health care that they want I mean Bernie
is running explicitly against the more
moderate wing of the Democratic Party
and this is particularly true with Obama
remember Obamacare is the system on the
books and it is failing and Democrats
are explicitly rejecting that what you
hear from Democrats is that the economy
has been slow for years suddenly the
booming economy we were told about in
2012 no longer exists now is that the
economy has been slow and slow and now
we're gonna fix all of that and
Obamacare is bad it turns out so for
example President Trump tweeted out
today everybody agrees that Obamacare
doesn't work premiums and deductibles
are far too high really bad health care
even Democrats wanna replace it both
Medicare for all so Bernie Sanders
Suites back medica fall well in the
atrocity of a profit-driven health care
system in which thousands died because
they cannot afford care Donald Trump
wants to protect insurance company
profits over American lives mr. Trump we
will defeat you in 2020 will make health
care a right well such as Sanders
running against Donald Trump that is
Sanders running against Obama I mean
what happens the first time on a debate
stage that Joe Biden starts talking
about health care and Bernie Sanders
says we were pushing for Medicare for
all and you and President Obama shut
that down you wouldn't even allow a
public option what happens the first
time
Bernie turns to Biden and says you need
to own Obama care since it was your
creation and then Biden has to admit one
of two things either that they lied to
the American public they said that Obama
care was the final the final stop not a
weigh station on the way to Medicare for
all or he has to own it how's that gonna
work out for him by the way the the in
the insipid stupidity of suggesting that
a profit-driven health care system can
be replaced by a non profit driven
health care system and that this will
not impact the level of care prevalent
in the United States is absolute sheer
nonsense it's simply nonsensical if you
want to force doctors to take less
pay you will get fewer doctors if you
want Medicare reimbursement rates which
are like 60% of private health care
insurance rates to be the prevalent
insurance rates fewer people are going
to go into medicine we already have a
shortage of doctors in the United States
if you want to continue regulating the
way that the Democrats want to regulate
with medical licensure you don't end up
with a shortage of doctors this is the
way to do it if you want to prevent 52%
of all new medical innovations being
produced in the United States Medicare
for all is a wonderful way to get that
done if you want to outlaw 160 million
private health care plans that people
own man go for it but if you think
that's not going to have an impact on
health care you got that wrong one of
the great lies about the American health
care system is that the American health
care system is truly horribly awful
there are problems with it
the employer based health care system is
a mistake you should not have to be
employed to have health care we should
all basically have our own individual
health care plans that we shop for it
should be consumer products groups that
evaluate all of these plans for us as
opposed to the group plans that you get
through your employer there are ways
that we can help fix all of this
Medicare for all is not the way to do
this and to pretend that the American
health care system generates worse
health care for the price is to ignore
the fact that on a GDP per capita basis
we are not wildly out of step with many
European countries and also to neglect
the fact that we have the highest
five-year cancer survival rates in the
world and that when you eliminate
homicide and car accidents vehicular
death in the United States we actually
the highest life expectancy in the
industrialized world we have wildly
outsized numbers of car deaths as well
as homicides in the United States in a
second we're gonna get to the other
Democratic candidates who as you see are
also rejecting the Obama legacy what
we're watching right now is a party in
flux and moving beyond its past and that
passed shockingly is Barack Obama it's
more of that in just a second first
let's talk about that cell phone
coverage there are a lot of things in
life that aren't right carpet and
showers chunky milk paying too much for
your phone bill
that's not right but thanks to Mint
mobile you don't have to overpay for
Wireless anymore with mint mobile you
can cut your wireless bill down to just
15 bucks a month
they've reimagined Wireless making it
easy and online-only which means they
can pass significant savings directly to
you mint mobile makes it easy to cut
your wireless bill down to just 15 bucks
a month you can use your own phone with
any mint mobile plan you can keep your
old number along with all your existing
contacts with mint mobile choose between
plans with 3 8 or 12 gigabytes of 4G LTE
data
stop paying for unlimited data you're
never gonna use it's easy to get
suckered into hey you need unlimited
data very few of us do every plan comes
with unlimited nationwide talk antics
and if you're not a hundred percent
satisfied Maine Mobile has you covered
with their seven day money-back
guarantee ditch that old wireless bill
start saving with mint mobile to get
that new wireless plan for just fifteen
bucks a month get the plan shipped to
your door for free go to mint mobile.com
slash Ben that is mint mobile.com slash
man cut your wireless bill to fifteen
bucks a month get free shipping on your
mint mobile plan and mint mobile comm
slash Penn that is mint mobile comm
slash Ben go check it out right now okay
in just a second when we get to the rest
of the Democratic Party candidates plus
some bad news for these fresh faces and
the Democratic Party and a couple of
comments on equal pay day today is
supposedly equal pay day the day upon
which women would have to work basically
this is the day when women would start
working if they were equaling the pay
rate of men to earn the same as men I'll
explain in just a little while why
that's so incredibly dumb but first
you're gonna have to go over to daily
wire comm for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription to daily wire comm when
you do you get the rest of our show live
and you also get two additional hours
every afternoon which has tons of great
material you also get this the very
greatest and beverage vessels look at it
the leftist years hot or cold tumbler
magnificent refreshing you refreshing
your mind body and soul day in and day
out that's left his tears
hot or cold tumblr people love it and
you will too when you get that 99 dollar
annual subscription which is cheaper
than the monthly also yet early access
to our Sunday special well this week you
are definitely gonna want early access
to our Sunday special because Andrew
yang is stopping by which should be a
blast
the first major Democratic Party
presidential candidate to stop by I'm
really excited about it because frankly
any Democrat who stops by Rises
significantly in my estimation for
having the willingness to actually sit
down we've offered a man people boo de
jedge had suggested maybe he would come
on he has been unresponsive to follow up
but his folks who actually listened to
or watched the Sunday special no it's
not a debate for them it is a place for
discussion of issues and as you'll see I
think with the Andrew yang interview
it's really really good I'm pretty
excited about that you get that a day
early when you subscribe plus you get to
hear all of the content behind the
paywall because there are a couple extra
questions you don't get to hear if you
are just a normal human being but not a
subscriber so go check that out
also subscribe over at YouTube or iTunes
we have all sorts of goodies for you
coming all the time we are working our
fingers to the bone for you folks it
goes subscribe right now we're the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so it is not just Bernie Sanders who's
running explicitly in the anti Obama
Lane it's also people like beta O'Rourke
so bado who is maintaining this kind of
10 to 12 percent hold even though he's
declared he hasn't had the sort of take
off that you want neither as commonly
Harris neither of them are picking up
significant steam at this point
nonetheless bado is making his break
with the Obama era as well yeah right
he's radical he likes to skateboard
he likes have bangs in his eyes let's
flip him Adams I hear little owns one
outfits his beta
he only owns a blue shirt and jeans
because he's a very down-to-earth
millionaire who made a career out of
being extremely rich from birth yeah
really one of the people anyway bado is
now beta is so radical that he is moving
back the timeline that we have to save
the earth from climate change now you'll
remember that in 2008 Barack Obama
suggested that we were that was the
moment that the Earth's Seas would begin
to recede that was not true also he
suggested he was going to take harsh
action about climate change that also
was not true the Democrats are disowning
the legacy of Obama on all of this stuff
by embracing this catastrophic view of
the future of climate change here is
beta at the We the People conference
yeah saying that we so aoc had said we
have 12 years to confront climate change
now baito says we only have 10 years to
confront climate change so guess what
guys you just lost two years off their
lives congratulations thanks bado think
about climate change at this point there
can be no shadow of a doubt that our own
excesses and emissions and inaction
politically and as a country in a
democracy have led to the warming that
we've seen so far 1 degrees Celsius just
since 1980 and along this current
trajectory the fires the droughts the
floods the devastation that we are
witnessing right now will only become
profoundly worse if we are going to
confront any of these challenges there's
challenges to the economy or a system of
health care or public education or
confronting climate change before it is
too late
within the 10 years that we have left to
us to act then the single greatest
mechanism that humankind is Everitt of
to call forth the power of the people a
democracy must be fixed okay first of
all the single greatest mechanism for
calling forth the power of the people is
not democracy it's free markets because
that is the individual democracy has
very often ended in tyranny Germany was
a democracy before it was a tyranny
Italy was a democracy before was a
tyranny Japan was a was a quasi
democracy before it was a tyranny I mean
that this is this is very silly but
beyond that when bethe auric says things
like we only have ten years to confront
climate change what he's implicitly
doing is ripping the Obama
administration so again there's this
break between the new woke progressive
left and the Obama era which spells doom
for Joe Biden I mean I think Joe Biden
is a is a paper tiger of a candidate I
think he's got a real problem on his
hands maybe there are some members of
the older Democratic base who like him
that's not enough to help him survive as
all fire is trained upon him and you can
see where everybody thinks the
Democratic base is they think it is to
the radical left and you can see that
from fringe candidates like jay inslee
jay Inslee is the governor of Washington
no one knows why in the hell he is
running
[Music]
I mean this is jay inslee theme song all
he cares about is climate change but
apparently not only does he talk a lot
about about climate change also he is
deeply concerned about implicit bias
talking about climate that they're a
bunch of people on the Left who suggest
that it is climate denial to point out
that if we do not end all of the all of
the carbon emissions in the United
States if we do all that it still won't
end climate change that's climate denial
but it is not science denial to continue
to promulgate myths like the idea that
implicit bias is something that is
easily measurable and also has an impact
on our lives jay Inslee spouting a bunch
of a scientific garbage in the name of
of course Vulcanus some local official
in a you know sort of non enlightened
area it doesn't understand why implicit
bias is a bad thing we do in my state in
fact I have my cabinet members take
training and implicit bias because we
believe in diversity in my state but
some of those places they don't quite
get it and if they're in charge where
the voting machines go you know where
those voting machine is gonna go they're
not going to go in the black
neighborhoods we got to make sure
everybody can vote we need a federal law
that allow a mail-in ballot now there's
some other things we got to do too I do
believe there's some reform we need we
need to end the electoral college so we
can have popular vote in this country
again very funny to watch the entire
Democratic Party also embrace an end to
the electoral college because obviously
they are angry that Hillary Clinton lost
but here's the point when Inslee talks
about implicit bias it is under jay
Inslee auspices that the City of Seattle
has become a crime center that it has
become a center for homelessness crime
rates are rising in the city of Seattle
and that's because Inslee and people
like him have been cracking down on
quote-unquote implicit bias at police
departments now implicit bias the
implicit bias assessment tests are
garbage they're just scientific garbage
when jesse single had a long piece of
while ago I believe is at The New Yorker
talking about the problems with implicit
bias assessment tests the people who
actually created those tests say that
they are not usable for practical
purposes these are the tests that you
will hear your your college student come
back with or if you're a college student
you've seen it in your classes where
people say okay well you're going to
click a button on your
computer every time you see a black face
and a nice word and people are slower to
click when it's a black face and a nice
word then they are when it's a white
face and a nice word and this is
supposedly implicit bias this is because
secretly deep down you have imbibed
certain stereotypes about black people
because secretly are racist there are a
bunch of problems with this test one is
that is not so clickable you can take it
twice and you can do better than the
second time then you can the first time
well when you are measuring in an eighth
quality and a human being that's not
supposed to be the case if I give you a
test if I give you a test an IQ test the
point of an IQ test and its durability
is that you can take it twice and you're
not gonna score any higher the second
time then you did the first time
implicit by a test can be game not only
that there is no real-world application
of implicit bias in other words there's
been zero studies showing that implicit
bias matches up to real-world bias in
any real way but jay Inslee is pushing
this why because we are now moving into
the realm of ghosts when it comes to
pushing leftist policy what I mean by
that is that if you want to attribute
everything in the United States all
disparities to discrimination all you
have to do is cite an unmeasurable force
for that disparity and then if people
deny the unmeasurable force then they
are considered unwell so if I say listen
you don't have any evidence that this
disparity is caused by widespread
discrimination as opposed to for example
bad decision making that locates within
a particular group statistically if I
say that that is considered done woke
but if you say white privilege is a
thing and so is implicit bias and then I
say ok your evidence please and then you
present me with no evidence other than a
bad test and you say if you don't
believe in the test you hate science I
mean this is some pretty woke stuff the
Democratic party nominees note the
candidates know where they think their
bread is buttered there's a wide open
lane to the moderate left for the
Democratic Party Biden is the only one
trying to fill it and he'll be torn down
forthwith I mean he'll be torn down
incredibly quickly ok speaking of lack
of moderation inside the Democratic
Party the fresh faces of the Democratic
Party are running into a little bit of
trouble so AOC continues to run
roughshod through the media the media
continue to prop her up as some sort of
grand idea master now I will acknowledge
I actually have a quick apology to make
to a OC yesterday I suggested that when
she talked about regenerative
agriculture I didn't know that was a
thing
didn't apparently it is a thing there's
some problems with regenerative
agriculture as a solution to carbon
emissions namely that yields on
regenerative agriculture this is
basically less tillage planting all
sorts of diverse crops on top of a field
instead of planting one type of crop it
dramatically lowers yields but that is a
thing so I apologize for not knowing
about that thing but aoc doesn't know
about any of the things so here's the
problems who aoc yesterday's tweets
about economics and this is considered
her being brilliant and wise she tweeted
yesterday croissants at LaGuardia are
going for seven dollars a piece yet some
people think getting a whole hour of
personal dedicated human labour for 15
bucks is too expensive yes yes actually
so a couple of things one the reason
that croissants at LaGuardia are
expensive is because all of the
companies there have a virtual monopoly
because the government only allows a
certain number of food shops there and
then they limit the ability to ship
croissants into the airport second the
actual price of a croissant at LaGuardia
Airport is 329 the Washington free
beacon went and checked it out
third the minimum wage at LaGuardia
Airport for this type of work is $19 now
are not $15 an hour and finally when she
suggests that if the croissants are $7
that we should be paying higher minimum
wage does she not understand that inputs
determine price that if you raise the
price of labor people are going to raise
the price of the croissant so the logic
goes something like this
man this croissant is so expensive seven
bucks that's a lot of money for a
croissant aren't people worth more let's
pay them $17 an hour instead of $15 an
hour so the companies are like okay and
then they raise the price of the
croissant to nine bucks and then aoc is
like whoa a $9 croissant and you say you
can only afford 17 bucks for human labor
how about 19 bucks they're like okay
they move it to 19 bucks and now the
croissants 11 bucks like whoa $11
croissants I mean that means that we
should really take that $90 and make it
$21 maybe you can afford an $11
croissant shouldn't we be paying people
more for labor you see how dumb this is
you raise the price of inputs you raise
the price of the product one of the
reasons the croissants are as
high-priced as they are is because of
the price of labor inputs also I love
when people like AOC suggests that they
know more than the entire market
mechanism I'd like to see OC trace from
beginning to end the production of the
croissant and explain where all of the
evil
making is happening so AOC recognized
that this was done and then she tweeted
out GOP taking every tweet so earnestly
making my point for me so basically she
is Trump she is Trump take me seriously
but not literally it's not an argument
against the price of a croissant it's
about the value of human worth but I
guess that idea is foreign to them since
their policies treat people as
disposable anyway so in other words when
I said it's complete nonsense but
Republicans hate humans I have a
question if a OC believes that the value
of labor is the same as the value of
human worth why isn't minimum wage
infinite I assume she thinks that every
human life is worth infinity is worth
infinity so infinity divided by any
finite number is still infinity so why
exactly isn't the minimum wage infinity
we should pay infinity dollars since
apparently that's how we value human
worth is in infinite numbers a OC but
she's so brilliant I mean I've been told
by the media that she is in fact a
spokesperson for my generation which is
deeply devastating for my generation
meanwhile Hunnam are another one of the
fresh faces of the Democratic Party has
some troubles of her own apparently
Ilhan Omar is now facing a campaign
finance probe that is not good for James
Rosen from Sinclair investigating quote
representative Ilhan Omar Democrat of
Minnesota the controversial freshman
House Democrat aside who is an
anti-semite is soon to learn the results
of a probe into her campaign spending as
a state lawmaker in Minnesota Sinclair
has learned with authorities there
having recently completed their
investigation and preparing to issue
rulings in a pair of complaints omar
faces the complaints were filed last
year while omar cruz to election to the
House of Representatives by a Republican
state lawmaker representative Steve
Drew's address Kowski in referring Omar
to the Minnesota Campaign Finance Board
Drazkowski alleged that Omar improperly
spent close to six thousand dollars in
campaign funds for personal use
including payments to her divorce
attorney and for travel to Boston and
Estonia Tresckow skis filing of the two
complaints followed in earlier episode
in which Omar repaid 2,500 bucks for
honorary guess she received for speeches
at colleges that receive state funding a
violation of ethics rules for Minnesota
lawmakers I had long observed a pattern
Drazkowski told Sinclair representative
Omar hasn't followed the law she's
repeatedly trampled on the laws of the
state in a variety of areas and gotten
away with this this follows on
accusations against AOC
that she too was messing around with her
campaign financing so as to funnel money
to her chief of staff who was running an
sort of anonymous LLC approached by
Sinclair oh my refused to answer any
questions about the campaign finance
allegations the aides suggested Sinclair
tried to schedule an interview instead
when Sinclair contacted her spokesman
Jeremy Slevin for that purpose he's
directed that the inquiry be routed to
his personal email accounts an inquiry
subsequently sent to that account
produced at no reply from its Levin the
Minnesota Campaign Finance Board
following standard practice declined to
confirm or deny whether his open and
investigation into the subject of any
complaints so sad it looks like the
swamp applies to a lot of the brand-new
fresh faces of the Democratic Party
what's amazing is that if you look at
the history of the Democratic Party the
the most loved Democrats are the ones
who were able to at least in rhetoric
tack to the center Bill Clinton was able
to rhetorically tack to the center and
play centrist even though in his early
policy he showed that he was very far to
the left
Barack Obama was able to rhetorically
sometimes tack to the center late in his
administration he stopped tacking to the
center and he simply said what he felt
which was out-and-out hardcore and
leftism but when he ran in 2008 he ran
as a centrist and he won a sweeping
victory Democrats however have basically
forbidden that they're embracing their
it'd in response to Donald Trump Donald
Trump has basically driven them insane
and they believe that because Donald
Trump is the it of the Republican Party
they need to now feed their own it
that's why I was asked by a reporter
from Politico this morning why I've been
complimentary toward Pete but a judge
the mayor of South Bend I said because I
don't think that while we disagree on
all policy
he doesn't seem angry at the country he
doesn't seem as though he is enraged at
the state of politics he seems as though
he wants to have a rational conversation
the fact that that alone is that winning
quality is being completely ignored by
the Democratic Party right now and
instead they are embracing their
angriest face we'll see how that works
out for them in future election cycles
I'm not sure it's gonna work out as well
as they think it will okay time for some
things that I like and then some things
that I hate so things that I like today
there's a series on Netflix that's
really creative and interesting it's
called love at death and robots it is
directed by David Fincher produced by
David Fincher and what's kind of fun
about this is that it's a series of
little vignettes none of them longer
than about 13/4
minutes david fincher basically decided
I'm sick of being forced by convention
to tell stories in an hour and a half
long version and people's attention
spans don't dictate that anyway and so
he took a bunch of stories and crammed
them into seven or eight minutes the
animation on the stuff is just beautiful
I mean the imagery on it is truly
incredible now it is very r-rated I mean
it's it's pornographic in certain areas
for sure and every style of animation is
wildly different but artistically
speaking it's some of the it's some of
the most artistic beautiful stuff I've
ever seen on a small screen and the
format of it which is that you can sort
of digest it in bite-sized chunks is
pretty neat it's all sci-fi based so if
you're into that sort of thing go check
it out love death and robots III kind of
loved the new format actually because my
feeling is that virtually all movies
have gotten too long if you go back to
the 1930s and 40s and even the 50s there
were a lot of movies Hollywood was
producing there were an hour and a half
that was plenty now there's a feeling
every movie has to be two hours very few
of them actually earn that sort of
billing love death and robots doesn't
even try so good for them okay time for
a quick thing that I hate so let us talk
about equal pay day supposedly equal pay
day is today it's an equal pay day is
apparently the day on which women
apparently would would have to continue
working to earn the same income that men
earned in 2018 so in other words women
would have to work all of last year and
all the way up to April 2nd to earn the
same pay that men earned in 2018 now
this statistic is absolute sheer
nonsense because it is just comparing
the gross average pay meaning they're
just taking paid to women versus pay to
men that does not take into account
hours worked it doesn't take into
account the kind of job it doesn't take
into account time off from the workforce
it doesn't take into account any of the
of the things that make this calculation
more complicated and that show that men
and women are effectively being paid the
same in the United States right now and
yet we continue to be for that they
continue to voice this nonsense on us
the National Committee on Pay Equity
keeps publicizing equal pay day as a
thing it is not in fact a statistical
thing it is very stupid well there is
something else that ought to be taken
into account if we're gonna take into
account all of this that is equal
occupational fatality
yeah this is introduced
by the American Enterprise Institute and
in particular a person in mark Perry he
talks about equal occupational
fatalities a that was the day that men
would have to that men would have to
work to sorry that women would have to
work to to have the same number of
annual deaths on the on the worksite as
men do so in other words for all the
deaths that men had in 2018 on the
worksite how far into the future world
women have to work in order for them to
achieve that number of deaths on the
work side since we are just going to
take grocery aggregate statistics and
not take into account the job choices
how far would men have to work it tells
us how many years and days into the
future women will be able to continue to
work before they will experience the
same number of occupational fatalities
that occurred for men in the previous
year well in 2017 four thousand seven
hundred sixty-one men died on the job
that is ninety two point five percent of
the total compared to three hundred
eighty six women seven point five
percent of the total based on those data
the next equal occupational fatalities a
will occur on May thirtieth twenty
thirty so women will have to work all
the way till May twenty thirty to
symbolize how far into the future they
will be able to continue working before
they experience the same number of
deaths that men experienced in 2017 and
of course it is true that the gender
occupational fatalities a box plays part
of the gender earnings gap because a
disproportionate number of men are
taking hype a high-risk jobs like
commercial fishing or logging or roofers
or truck drivers or electric power line
workers women far outnumber men in
relatively low risk industries as
pointed out by AEI sometimes with lower
paid to partially compensate for these
safer more comfortable indoor office
environments in occupations like office
and administrative support where women
constitute about seventy-two percent of
the workforce education training library
occupations and health care the higher
concentrations of men in riskier
occupations with greater occurrences of
workplace injuries and fatalities
suggest that more men than women are
willing to expose themselves to
work-related injury or death in exchange
for higher wages the proponents of equal
pay day are promoting a statistical
falsehood by suggesting that women
working side-by-side with men in the
same occupation for the same company are
making something like twenty percent
less than their male counterparts it is
just not true
it is simply
true by the way it is it is also worth
noting here that all of the attempts by
the left to equal this out with things
such as mandatory mandatory paid
government pregnancy leave attempts like
this that allow this sort of thing
actually put women on a lower track to
management we've seen this in the Nordic
countries there is a more women are in
management in places like the United
States than are in management in places
like Norway why because women are taking
advantage of that paid time off and
meant or not and so men are simply
rising on the pay scale faster than
women in places like Norway so all the
attempts to alleviate the problem of the
of the supposed pay gap are actually
exacerbated by government intervention
ISM in these areas like a final thing
that I hate so Alyssa Milano who we've
referred to earlier her Twitter account
is just a cornucopia of wonder she
tweeted out yesterday I love God I
believe in God but I don't believe my
personal beliefs of which we can't
confirm should override scientific facts
and what we can confirm quote if I have
told you earthly things and you do not
believe how can you believe if I tell
you heavenly things John 3:12 my
favorite thing is when people quote the
Bible and miss all the places where God
talks about I have formed you in the
womb and I knew you before you were born
you know all of the areas where God
talks about how he is not particularly
in favor of killing in the womb but
we'll find a vague reverse in which even
that doesn't back her even John 3:12
doesn't peck Alyssa Milano you know what
is it one of those earthly things that
that God told us is that there are
babies in the womb they exist in the
womb I love the fact that she says that
it is not a scientific fact that there
is a baby in the womb I'd love to hear
her talk about the scientific facts on
biological sex by the way that would be
definitely amusing and now Alyssa Milano
is saying you know I don't want
theocracy it's not I don't believe that
my perspectives on abortion should trump
the science how about the science
trumping your perspective on abortion
Alyssa Milano because that's the actual
reality okay well enough of Alyssa
Milano we'll be back here a little bit
later today with two additional hours of
the program go out and buy my number one
New York Times bestseller the right side
of history it is still on sale
everywhere it is extraordinarily
available and prevalent and legitimately
probably a hundred thousand people have
already bought that book it's it's it's
doing really well so I urge you to be
part of the conversation go check it out
the right side of history and get it at
Amazon today
check us out later today or we'll see
you back here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam SIA
vets audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
I'm Michael Knowles host of the Michael
Noel's show the left launches a crusade
to murder innocent babies in Georgia
while simultaneously trying to overturn
the death penalty for rapists and
murderers we will examine the left
inverted judgment and the importance of
good judges check it out at daily wire
calm